let me ask this question yeah sure bud
it seems to me that your guys are
defined because you're finding common
ground here there's not a lot that you
you've said that has that have been
disagreeable yes
what are the the code of conduct of the
rules like for instance
i i asked these questions on
saskatchewan on the show that i host
that you guys have been on who pays on
the first date well the man you know if
a fight breaks out you want a man to
protect you okay man hold a door
chivalry
what are the code of conduct
that women need to abide by do these
things like the sandwich example and
what are the code of contact that men
need to bring to the table there seems
to be that the men have to do this bing
bing bing make more money do this
protect the household you know bring
home the bacon what are the code of
contact that men need to do and what is
the code of conduct that women need to
do and if there's an agreement here i'd
love to hear it yeah i mean the the
biggest thing is that you know men have
to always bring something to the table
there is an invisible burden performance
on men to bring certain things to the
table and and society you know applauds
it yeah man up do this other stuff but i
if i say hey well ladies we need you to
do this this and this we get a lot of
backlash for that in other words what
men want is typically almost always
demonized whereas what women want is
considered preferences but what we want
is considered discrimination so if i was
to say for example i don't want to date
no fat hoes oh my god that is so fat
shaming that's [ __ ] up but if i was to
say oh well but if a woman wants to say
i don't want no broke iron no ugly guy
or no small dick energy guy or whatever
the hell it is no one bats perfectly
it's completely it's completely socially
acceptable for yourselves about it shame
men nobody wants one minute man no one's
you know yeah small dick man all that so
in other words it is okay for women to
have standards and not men and that's
what i'm saying like where guys need to
kind of come in and put standards on
women because a lot of girls just think
i'm going to show up on a date and be
pretty and that's it and i don't got to
worry about nothing else and this guy's
got to impress me and i'm telling guys
no you got to make girls perform too
because too many girls are used to
getting attention and validation for
nothing more than breathing so what do
they need to do to perform so i would
say the biggest thing is every guy is
different right they're gonna have
different things but most men are easy
to please as long as a woman is
compliant submissive feminine attractive
pleasant to be around not annoying like
you're gonna be have a lot of guys uh
happy just with that you know what i'm
saying then every other guy depending on
what they want you know maybe an
entrepreneur they're gonna need help or
whatever but a lot of women come into
the relationship thinking what can you
do for me versus what they need to do is
come into the relationship thinking what
can i do for you because at the end of
the day i think women always make the a
really bad mistake where they think oh
well i have a bunch of guys hit me up
whatever no your game is can you retain
the guy that you like in my own respect
the guy's game is can i attain the girl
the girls game is can i retain the guy
after i [ __ ] him and if you were to ask
a lot of modern day women they can't
retain these dudes that's why a lot of
them are chronically single guys ain't
[ __ ] blah blah it's because their
retention value sucks because they come
in from the perspective of let me get
what i can i'm gonna come in as a
liability versus being an asset a lot of
girls are liabilities i'm gonna be
honest so here's the biggest problem
right that i see it from the podcast
from dating actually being out there in
the field and it's scary because most
women never think about it
they know what they want
to an example six feet six inches six
figures you know the typical the six
rule top percent guy
however they never asked question
what does that guy really want and as a
result they'll do the most oh i'm a boss
babe i have my own money i can buy a car
i can do this or not it's like no i
don't run another meet i want a girl's
feminine cousin to be around is peaceful
right men want peace however here's the
thing that most women need to understand
as well
what they need to do is bring value to
the guy and it could be anything for
example let's say i want a pizza shop
right and for me personally all i need
somewhere on saturdays when my staff is
not available
to take phone calls
it's just really into me guess what
she's gonna say you know what damn my
man needs this on saturday i'll make
time and adjust for him because he's my
man and i care about i respect him as a
result that's adding value like for
example it could be even in the gym you
know what he needs his protein shake at
10 am she says you know what i'll wake
up early make a forum and go back to
sleep that's adding value so we're just
saying for the most part most women they
don't even care or want to know what men
want they just say i want this guy
because he's high value but it's amazing
we've we've brought girls on the show
and they'll say i want this and i want
that we actually have something called
the delusion calculator it's kind of
funny and we have we one of our
supporters actually made and he and he
pulled stats from the u.s census bureau
and from the national health
organization right that compo has a
composite of like all the men in the
united states et cetera and they'll will
say okay i want a guy to be six feet
tall um so we have yeah that's that's
good
but we have our own that's the old one
we have a new updated one see the new
update uh i don't have the link here but
um we we've used it before and like
almost every time without fail when we
asked to go describe the guy from
standpoint how much money they make
whatever they're almost always describe
a guy in the top two or three percent of
men say over six feet tall 100 000 plus
whatever and then we ask okay so this is
what you wanted the guy what do you
bring back [ __ ] crickets man they
don't really know what to say they'll go
ahead and sometimes say something like
what he was saying like oh well i bring
my own money i bring my own stuff too
and a lot of women don't understand that
attraction is not symmetrical it's
asymmetrical men and women are attracted
to completely different things a lot of
girls don't understand this which is
also scary because they think why make
my own money i'm successful i'm
ambitious blah blah blah blah that's
great that sounds great on paper for you
but men don't necessarily care about
these things and they're like what are
you talking about blah blah blah and i'm
just like well if i decided you know i'm
gonna do my nails on saturdays and wear
heels every now and then and be you know
be very pretty and stuff you look at me
like i'm crazy right yeah that's not
attractive okay well that's how i feel
every time you come up and say i'm a
boss so i make this much money whatever
because whether women want to accept it
or not making money being successful et
cetera you tend to have masculine traits
when you are a go-getter and an a-type
personality and a lot of guys don't find
that attractive and the men that they're
competing for don't find these things
attractive because once a man has money
the last thing he cares about is a girl
that has money like that if she does
have it it's a plus but it's not
necessarily a requirement if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]